بيلاروسيا تستعد للدخول بشكل مباشر في
الحرب الاوكرانيه لكن بشروط بحسب السلطات
في منسك مسؤول رفيع المستوى في بيلاروسيا
قال ان الدول ان الدول المتحالفه او
الدوله المتحالفه مع روسيا والمجاوره
لاوكرانيا اي بيلاروسيا لديها ما يصل الى
مليون وخمسمائه الفرد وهم جاهزون للقتال
خارج قواتها المسلحه وكاله بلتا للانباء
نسبت الى سكرتير مجلس الامن البيلاروسي
الكسندور فولفوفيتش قوله ان هذا العدد
منفصل عن الجيش وانه سيوضع رهن الخدمه في
حاله اعلان الاحكام العرفيه ووضع الاقتصاد
في حاله الحرب وبحسب تقرير التوازن
العسكري الصادر عن المعهد الدولي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه يصل قوام الجيش في بيلاروسيا
الى نحو 48 الف جندي اضافه في حرس الحدود
في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر امر الرئيس
البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاتشينكو بتشكيل قوه
دفاع بريه جديده تضم متطوعين قد تضم ما
يقارب 150 الف شخص واكد لوكاتشينكو ان جيش
بلاده لم يحارب الا اذا هجمت بيلاروسيا
ويدعم رئيس بيلاروسيا نظيره الروسي في
حربه على اوكرانيا المستمره منذ عام وسمح
له بشن عمليات ضد اوكرانيا انطلاقا من
اراضي بيلاروسيا فضلا عن تدريب قوات حشدت
مؤخرا داخل البلاد
بيلاروسيا نفت اليوم عبر اداره الحدود صحه
الانباء عن تبادل لاطلاق النار يوم السبت
الماضي على الحدود مع اوكرانيا واشارت
الاداره الى ان المعلومات التي ينشرها من
وصفتهم بالمتطرفين لا علاقه لها بالواقع
ومع التوتر الذي يسود الحدود بين
بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا اعلنت الاخيره نيتها
توسيع عمق الشريط الحدودي المزروع
بالالغام على طول الحدود مع بيلاروسيا
وروسيا حتى مسافه كيلومترين من جانبها
اعلنت بيلاروسيا استعدادها التام للرد على
اي استفزاز المحتمل من الجانب الاوكراني
على حد وصف سلطات
واليوم اكد الرئيس بيلاروسي الكسندر ان
بامكان مينسك وموسكو انتاج اي نوع من
الاسلحه وبكميات كافيه على الرغم من
العقوبات اشاد لوكتشينكو بفضل روسيا التي
قال انها تزود بلاده بما يكفي من موده
اوليه لصنع ما يكفي من المعدات العسكريه
لي
الرئيس البيلاروسي قال ايضا ان منتجات
الاسلحه في بلاده يمكن تصديرها الى اكثر
من 50 دوله خاصه وان بيلاروسيا بحسب
رئيسها تنتج انواعا حديثه من الاسلحه
المطلوبه عالميا كاواريخ وذخيره المدفعيه
ذات العيار الثقيل
[موسيقى]
اود الاشاره الى انه على الرغم من ضغوط
العقوبات غير المسبوقه فاننا ننتج اسلحه
ومعدات عسكريه كافيه لاحتياجات الجيش
البيلاروسي ويرجع ذلك الى ان كل ما نحتاجه
من الاسلحه والحديد نحصل عليه بسهوله من
روسيا فيما يتعلق بالالكترونيات الدقيقه
والالكترونيات الضوئيه والبصريات وغيرها
فالفضل لاولئك الذين حافظوا على مرافق
الانتاج الموروثه من الاتحاد السوفيتي حيث
بامكاننا مع روسيا انتاج اي نوع من
الاسلحه